Transcriber: Lale ilyar
Gözden geçirme: Sancak Gülgen
Ben birkaç saniye sessizce düşünüp
acaba hayatınızda hayati derecede
önemli bir karar alıp almadığınızı,
sorgulamanızı istiyorum.
Hayati bir karar.
O kadar önemli durum ki bu,
hayatınız söz konusu olacak.
Çok da zannetmiyorum.
Var mı öyle bir karar alan aramızda?
Peki önemli bir karar alıp
almadığınızı düşünün.
Kişiden kişiye değişir önemli kararlar,
değil mi, hocam?
İş, yaşayacağımız şehir,
evlenmek
ya da çocuk sahibi olmak.
Hayatımızda günlük aldığımız kararlardan
biraz daha uzun vadeli gidişatımızı
etkileyen kararlar bunlar.
Önemli kararlar bizim için.
Vakit harcarız, düşünürüz, tartarız.
Bazen cayarız o kararı almaktan.
Ama ben size farklı bir durumdan
bahsedeceğim bugün.
O hayati kararları almak durumunda kalan
insanlardan bahsedeceğim.
Çok kısa zamanları olan,
başka seçim şansları olmadan,
hayatlarını kurtarmak için
o kararı almak zorunda kalan insanlardan.
İvra.
Kilis'te tanıştım ben onunla.
2013 yılında.
O zaman bölgedeki 1 milyonuncu
Suriyelinin kayıt olduğunu
simgelemesi üzerine
hayat hikayesini yaptık.
Herkesle paylaştık.
Aslında birçoğu gibi,
o da ailesinin aldığı o kararla
ülkesini terk etmek zorunda kalmış
ve başka bir ülkeden korunma talep etmiş
milyonlarcasından biri.
Sadece bir çocuk olması
belki onun annesinden ve babasından,
farkındalık açısından durumu
biraz değiştiriyordu.
Çünkü ne olduğunu anlamamıştı.
Konuşurken, yaşadıkları hayata
adapte olmaya çalışıyordu.
Çünkü sadece daha iki buçuk üç ay olmuştu
Türkiye’ye onlar sığınalı.
Çok içine kapandığını anlattı ailesi.
Şöyle bir günmüş o gün.
Okula gitmek üzere aslında
üniformasını giymiş.
Okula gidecek.
Çatışmalar devam ediyor.
Suriye’de zaten bir çatışma ortamı var.
Ama onlar etkilenmemiş durumdalar o zaman.
Evlerine 2 - 2,5 kilometre kadar yer
darmadağın olmuş. Saniyesinde.
Ve ailesinin çok fazla bir
şansı yokmuş aslında.
İvra’yı, kardeşlerini alıp
bir an önce diğerleri gibi
sınıra doğru koşmaktan başka.
Günlerce yürümüşler.
Türkiye’de bir müddet mülteci kampında
kaldıktan sonra,
kamptan ayrılmaya karar vermişler.
Kilis’te yardımlarla
yaşamlarını devam ettiriyorlardı.
Peki, onun en çok istediği ve özlediği şey
neymiş biliyor musunuz?
Konuşurken fark ettik.
Ne olduğunu anlamadan,
evinden koptuğu için
en çok özlediği şey,
yatağının üzerinde bıraktığı
oyuncak ayısıydı.
Birçoğunun gibi aslında.
Biz peki kimlerden bahsediyoruz?
Kaç kişiler onlar? Aramızdalar mı?
Evet aramızdalar.
60 milyon hayattan bahsediyorum size.
60 milyon insan.
Hepsi mülteci değil,
bir kısmı bunların ülkeleri içinde
yer değiştirmek zorunda kalan insanlar.
Yani henüz uluslararası bir sınırı açıp,
başka bir ülkenin korumasına
ihtiyacı olmamış insanlar.
Ama ülkelerini ve hayatlarını ve
her şeylerini geride bırakmış
olan insanlar.
Sayıları çok yüksek aslında
biliyor musunuz?
Gün gün ülkelerini terk eden
sayıları görüyorsunuz.
Her gün, geçtiğimiz 2014 yılında,
42 bin 500 kişi bütün hayatını
geride bırakarak başka bir ülkeye
gitmek zorunda kalanların bir kısmı.
Bazısı da başka bir şehre gitmiş,
kendi toprağı içinde.
Bunlar da aslında belki bugün
sizler gibi dışarıdan
bakıyorlardı bu duruma.
Kendilerine olmazlarmış gibi.
Ama hiç de o kadar
uzakta değiller aslında.
Aramızdalar.
Ve bu sayı dediğim gibi 60 milyona ulaştı.
Çok yüksek bir rakam.
Bugün burada kaç kişiyiz?
Tahminiz var mı?
Sanırım 300 civarında.
Bir 1 milyon kişiyi hayal edin.
Edebiliyor musunuz?
Ne kadar büyük bir hacim?
Peki 60 milyon insanı hayal edin.
Bizler gibi, sizin gibi.
60 milyon hayat.
Ne kadar büyük sizce bir düşünün.
Türkiye'nin nüfusu ne kadar?
79 milyon civarında değil mi?
Eğer bir milleti temsil ediyor olsalardı
bu 60 milyon kişi,
şu an dünyadaki en kalabalık
23’üncü ülke olacaklardı.
İngiltere’den sonra, İtalya’dan önce.
Ve o kadar çok hızlı artıyorlar ki,
yani dünyada devam eden
çatışmalar bitmiyor,
yerine yeni çatışmalar geliyor.
İşte; Yemen, Afganistan,
maalesef Orta Doğu'daki çatışmalar,
Afrika da.
Bunların üzerine bir de işte
son beş senededır yaşadığımız
mega kriz diye adlandırdığımız
Suriye durumu var,
Irak.
Komşularımız.
Hepsini biz birebir yaşıyoruz biz aslında.
Bu insanlar bizlerin arasında.
Biliyorsunuz 2014 sonunda
Türkiye en fazla sayıda mülteciye
ev sahipliği yapan ülke oldu.
Biz Türk misafirperverliğini,
Türkiye'nin onları almasına,
uyguladığı yardım politikasına
müteşekkiriz.
Bu olması gereken bir sorumluluk aslında.
Ama ne kadarı yapılıyor?
Sizce bu hayatlar nerelerde?
Donup kalıyorlar mı?
Sizce nasıl olmalılar?
Düşünün, İvra’yı düşünün.
Okulundan uzaklaştı ve okula gidemiyor.
Dil engeli var.
Biz ne yapabiliriz?
Uzaktan böyle bakmalı mıyız onlara sizce?
Hamo’yla, bay Hamo.
Kendisi doktor ama tıp doktoru değil.
İstanbul’da tanıştım ben.
Çok değişik bir kişilik
belki haberlerden izlemişsinizdir.
Çünkü hikayesi Amerika’da bitti.
Suriye’de çok önemli ve tanınan
bir mühendismiş kendisi.
Derecelerle okullarını bitirmiş,
üniversiteye üçüncülükle girmiş,
boş zamanlarında inşaat alanlarında
staj yaparak, parasını kazanarak,
kendine emek vermiş.
Daha sonra evlenmiş, çocukları olmuş.
Ve karısıyla tek emellerinin
çocuklarının iyi eğitim alarak
başarılı insanlar olmasını
sağlamak olduğunu tanımladı.
Öyle anlattı kendini bize.
Gelirken yanında,
yani o hayati kararı alıp,
ülkesini terk ederken,
yanında çizimlerini getirmiş.
Çünkü dedi ki;
“Çocuklarım kadar önemli
benim için onlar.
Emeğim var.
Onlar benim bir parçam.”
Almış gelmiş onları.
Bize onları gösterdi, gururla.
Bunu da gösterirken, çok duygulandı.
Çünkü o kaçış anlarını anlatırken,
bize nerede olduğunu söyledi.
Bu onun, Bay Hamo'nun yaptığı bir site.
O evlerden pembe olanında
kendi kardeşi oturuyormuş.
Solundakinde de kendisi.
Bombardıman başladığında,
kendi evde değilmiş.
Ama görebiliyormuş o bölgeyi ve
kardeşinin olduğu evin
darmadağın olduğunu görmüş.
Oraya doğru gitmişler,
kendi evinin en üst katında
karısı ve kızı varmış, büyük kızı.
Ve kendi evinin üst katı da etkilenmiş.
O gün o bombardımanda,
orada 16 kişi ölmüş.
Yedisi kendi ailesinden,
karısı ve kızı dahil.
Diğer kalan iki çocuğuyla beraber
Türkiye’ye sığınmışlar.
İki senedir Türkiye'deydi
ben tanıştığımda.
Ağır bir kanser geçiriyordu.
Sonradan çıkmış bu hastalığı.
Tıbbi destek alıyordu.
Ama kendisinin mülteci olarak
tanımlanmasını istemiyordu.
Yaşadığı o kadar acıya rağmen,
“Benim bir adım var.
Ben emek verdim.
Beni sayılarla anmayın.
O milyonların içinden
biri olmak istemiyorum.
Ben de sizler gibiyim.” dedi yani.
“Emek verdim, çalıştım, başardım,
hatta çok da büyük kayıplar verdim.
Ve mecbur kaldım,
ülkemi de geride bıraktım.
Hayatımı bıraktım ama hayatım şu an dondu.
Fırsat istiyorum, çalışmak istiyorum.”
Sizce bunları hak etmiyorlar mı?
Yarısı çocuk olan bir toplumdan
bahsediyorum ben size.
O 60 milyonun yarısı çocuk.
Kayıp gençlik,
genç bir nesil ister miyiz?
Hangimize yarar bu?
Kimseye yaramaz bence.
Düşünün ki 17 yıl
bir mülteci hayatının ortalaması.
17 yıl boyunca ki bu bazen nesiller sürüyor.
Çünkü mülteci olmak
hiç de normal bir durum değil.
Yani ülkenizi terk ediyorsunuz,
her şeyinizi geride bırakıyorsunuz,
cebinizde sizi tanıtacak
belki hiçbir şey yok.
Düşünün kimlik kartımız yok,
ne yaparız?
Hastaneye gidebilir misiniz?
Okula kayıt olun, hadi!
Seyahat edelim.
Kimden yardım isteyeceğiz ya?
Düşünsenize böyle hayat.
Aslında çok hassas bir grup,
ama bir o kadar da kuvvetli bir grup.
Ben o yüzden
çok saygı duyuyorum onlara.
Her seferinde, her konuştuğumda
çok şey öğreniyorum onlardan.
Şimdi sizlerin onlara
uzaktan bakmanızı istemiyorum.
Uzaktan bakmayın.
Bay Hamo onu istiyordu.
Amerika’ya yerleşti,
üçüncü ülke programı dediğimiz
maalesef kotaları çok kısıtlı olan
bir programımız var.
Bu üçüncü ülkelerden kaynaklanıyor.
Açtıkları kotaların sınırı yüzünden.
Yani sadece mülteci nüfusunun %1'nin
elde edebildiği bir durum bu.
Onlardan biri oldu
ve Amerika’ya yerleşti.
Hatta Amerikan başkanı Obama’nın
veda yemeğine gitti.
Konuşmasına gitti.
Mültecileri temsilen,
seslerini duyurmak için.
Bence hepsi bunu hak ediyor.
Onları görmeye çalışın.
Aramızdalar.
Türkiye’de dediğim gibi
bugün 3 milyon kişi var, yaşayan.
Hamo dediğim gibi size
gelirken,
elinde
çizimlerini alıp gelebilmişti.
O anda onu düşünmüş.
Birçok insan farklı psikolojiye giriyor.
Aslında onlarla sonradan konuştuğunuzda
hiçbirinin o anı yaşayacağını tahmin
etmediğini duyuyorsunuz.
Yani diyor ki, hiç kimse herhalde
benim de aklıma gelmez.
Bir gün, kaçmak zorunda kalsam,
ne yapardım acaba diye hiç düşünmedim.
Hala daha da uzak geliyor.
Ama o kadar uzak değil inanın.
Yani bu hiç kimsenin dünyada
yaşamaması gereken bir durum.
Ama o insanlar da bizlerden biri.
Omar, Irak’ta o anlık kararı verirken,
evinin anahtarını alıp çıkmış,
kapısını da kitlemiş.
Dönerim diye.
Biz tanıştığımızda
dört buçuk senedir mülteciydi.
Evi de muhtemelen yerle bir.
Güney Sudan’dan.
10 yaşında.
Maymunuymuş en iyi arkadaşı,
onu almış kaçmış, ailesinin yanında.
Hiçbir şey de anlamamış.
Nereye gittiklerini,
ne yaptıklarını bilmeden.
Umutlarını, okulunu, arkadaşlarını,
bırakmış; yeni bir hayat,
bilinmezliğe doğru gitmiş.
Benjamin, Kongo’da.
Bir mülteci kampında çalışıyor.
Sırtlamış dikiş makinasını.
“Hayatımı onunla kazanıyorum,
nasıl para kazanacağım yoksa?
Çocuklarım var, nasıl yeticem onlara?”
demişti, görüşmemizde.
Tamara,
Adıyaman mülteci kampında bir öğretmen.
Suriyeli.
“Çocuklara ulaşmaya
devam etmek istiyorum.” dedi.
“Öğretmenim ben, diplomam bu.
Diplomamı aldım geldim.
Fırsat verin,
devam edeyim.”
Şimdi ben sizden küçücük bu zamanda,
azıcık da olsa mültecilerin hayatlarına
dokunmanızı istiyorum.
Onlar o anı hiç düşünmediler,
hiç tahmin etmediler.
Şimdi siz bir dakika düşünün.
Ve lütfen sen olsaydın?
O an, kısacık bir zamanın olsaydı
ve o hayati kararı almak zorunda olsaydın,
yanına ne alırdın?
Teşekkür ederim.
BÇ: Çok ağır bir konu aslında.
Yani, biz hepimiz bu konunun
çok içindeyiz.
Türkiye bunun içinde,
çok fazla içinde hem de.
Yani bunlar hep
rakam olarak duyuyoruz biz,
her zaman rakam olarak duyuyoruz.
Siz onlarla birebir çalışıyorsunuz,
sınırda.
Biz sizle görüştüğümüz zaman
Ürdün’de oluyorsunuz,
başka yerde oluyorsunuz.
Bu insanlarla birebir yaşamak
sizi zorlamıyor mu?
Yani çok fazla hikayeler anlattınız, nasıl,
gittiğinizde düşünmüyor musunuz bunları?
SÜ: Tabii ki çok düşünüyorum.
Dedim ya, çok fazla şey
öğreniyorum ben onlardan.
Çünkü, ben olsaydım
ne yapardım onların yerinde.
O kadar dayanıklı olabilir miydim,
onu çok sorguladım en başta.
Çok etkileniyorsunuz.
Ve aslında o yüzden de
ben bu işi yapıyorum.
Seslerini duyurabilmek için.
Onları sayı olarak
hatırlamanızı istemiyoruz.
Onlar o şekilde
hatırlanmak istemiyorlar.
Onlar bir hayat bizim gibi, umutları olan,
amaçları olan. Çabaladılar
ve maalesef kendileri dışında gelişen
bir durum yüzünden
o ortam içinde olmak zorundalar.
Ve sayı olarak bilinmek istemiyorlar.
İstatistikten çıkıp,
onların hayatına
dokunabilmemizi istiyorlar.
İşte, tabii ki bende onlardan
çok fazla şey öğreniyorum,
ve burda da paylaşmış olmaktan
çok mutluyum.
Teşekkür ederim.
BÇ: Biz de teşekkür ediyoruz.